so welcome to ee3 this is the first live
presentation in quite a long time
um and uh
uh I think that maybe half of the
remaining presentations are going to end
up being live uh the um
problems uh in getting things organized
this this year were surprisingly art
but I think things are back in in form
any case um our speaker today is Alan
Huang he's um
he writes the best patents I've ever
seen
uh they're um
uh so well constructed that I doubt very
much as the patent examiner ever manages
to read them
but they're lovely and he's uh really uh
an expert in networks he's a product of
Stanford from the computer systems lab
and uh a long time friend and um
everything everything good okay uh my
name is Alan Wong I just wanted to sort
of say uh the people in the room will
vouch for the fact I'm live I I have my
official Zoom uh formal sweatshirt but
since we're actually doing the camera
here and I'm actually wearing pants too
so they can vouch for that all right
after Stanford I've got my PhD here in
double e I joined ATT Bell Laboratories
as a researcher and my field uh is
computer networking and Optical
Communications
um I will talk to you about how to
optimize the internet and you're
probably thinking okay come on this is
hype you know you'll see how much hype
there is all right uh this is a map of
the internet uh it was done by uh
um Bill Cheswick and uh Hal Birch at
Bell Laboratories and they just mapped
out all of the internet as of uh 1997.
uh they there's no subsequent pictures
because they banned or they blocked
trace route out and now is the domain
way for gathering information but that's
what it used to look like
so what I'll be talking on this and this
talk is basically how to optimize this
sort of hairy carrier
um very hairball a little bit of
personal introduction the first thing I
did at Bell was something called The
Starlight packet switch it was a backer
Batcher Banyan switch uh the way it
worked is you would feed in uh basically
packets in cereal you had all these
little tiny State machines that all they
had to decide was to pass it through or
cross over the connections uh basically
the whole switch is made out of uh
hundreds of these little saint machines
each have only eight states you come in
from the top uh with those destinations
the first set is the concentrator just
squeezes them all over the center there
they come through here and then they
basically get sorted and then they go
into basically uh a banyan Network and
uh they can go through without conflicts
it was designed for a voice data and
video uh in 1982 we demonstrated 32
inputs at 100 megabits each it was the
fastest packet switch around
the idea for this switch came from uh
first of all I took too many courses
from Don knuth and so I sort of hung up
on sorting and so you see a lot of this
stuff has to do with sorting uh my
partner um Scott knauer is also from
Stafford uh he had a professor named uh
um Harold Stone and he came up with the
perfect Shuffle and so we'll be talking
more about the perfect Shuffle there's
no dancing involved so don't be afraid
it's just a regular Shuffle
all right overview what I'm going to say
talk about I'm going to first tell you
what does an optimal internet look like
and then I'll go on to say how can it be
implemented and the last thing how can
it be deployed
all right in terms of here are some
mathematically Optical networks and I'm
using the word optimal in a mathematics
point of view and not a marketing point
of view and it means that you just can't
do any better and so there's three
flavors of this network it's a banyan
butterfly and perfect Shuffle and
they're like a dozen papers doing
battles from various grad students and
professors about which was a better
Network and then some core grad student
discovered that they're all the same if
you sort of replace each one of these
nodes with a washer and you had sort of
elastics in between you can see you can
rearrange the middle row and they'll all
be the same so that was what we used to
call the fabric Wars but the important
thing is and inputs you can do it in log
uh and whereas m is the fan out of the
node you just can't do any better all
right one of the things I was really
troubled by was that when you read like
dozens and dozens of people they never
show why this is and so during covet I
just got fed up and says I'm going to do
it usually they sort of said oh it's up
to the reader or it's from group Theory
or whatever and here's the proof you
have uh inputs from a to H there to come
in and there's something called I call
it gene pool analysis basically you have
two genes here they're a b two genes
here CD and you come down here The
Inheritance is a b e f and you go down
here to your login level and you'll see
that you have one of every possible
input and that shows you connect any
input to any output
okay something strange happens when you
add an extra layer
all right when you add an extra layer
you double the amount of genes you get
and so what that indicates is that you
can have two paths to this network
so if you had a fan out of four
you'll see that you'll get four copies
of the input genes on at the bottom all
right and so this is where one of the
things if you ask a math minute you show
this to them and they'll say oh yeah
you're just overdriving your cyclic room
group generator and well it took me a
little time to figure that out you know
I'm not a mathematician all right but I
am an engineer and when you start to see
this network there's ways of sort of
super revving it up and one of the ways
you can rev up this network is you can
put in buy direct directional
connections and so instead of going
through the whole damn Network and then
you know you can basically back up and
go to the previous one and then come
back down and so there's all these other
it becomes a very rich way of moving
stuff around you get a lot of redundancy
and then when you sort of like tie the
bottom to the top again you sort of uh
do closure it sort of becomes a it's a
toroid and it's sort of like one of
those things uh any Chinese kid when
they go through the first banquet and
they encounter a lazy Susan they figured
out they can spin the Susan only Lazy
Susan only half the direction they don't
have to go the whole way around and so
this is the Lazy Susan uh feedback
all right
why is this important why is it
redundancy what why did you sort of put
these networks on steroids and it's
because redundancy can be used first of
all for congestion relief and they say
well what congestion it ends up that
what happened if you look at the various
Services email file transfer voice over
IP and video streaming
um
at the beginning here these destinations
are random you know there's no real
correlation between one nbml and another
where you're sending it and
unfortunately when you're talking about
video streaming all the packets go to
the same direction and so you get into
trouble in other words this is sort of
how random or packet-like and this
becomes circuit-like and this is what's
screwing up with a lot of the networks
that we have on the internet right now
uh it's one of the problems with
starlink it's one of the problems of all
those fancy computers at the arrays of
computers to have a Google
once you try to do things a larger uh uh
streams you get into trouble
so one of the things is observation is
when you're doing packet switching it's
statistical and you're sort of like
relying on the statistics to avoid
congestion and so instead of using they
use memory buffers to Temporary how
poorly spread out the congestion in the
old days in circuit switches you used to
use spatial redundancy you know there's
had none of connections you had other
cross points and you tried to move some
of your traffic there just to avoid
congestion
so
um the difference is in
telecommunications or old circuit
switching we knew we had a problem and
the packets which will they still
haven't quite figured that out yet
all right
um
you can also use redundancy for fault
tolerance and you say oh I know this
already you know I shouldn't go through
all this well in computer terms there's
something called tandem you're basically
sort of hooking two computers in
parallel and when smoke starts coming
out of one of them you switch to the
other the trouble is okay this requires
twice the hardware and you're only
getting half the productivity in other
words you're only doing you're only
doing half the useful work
uh then there's a fancy one to do
military and space use that's majority
vote so you're using three times the
hardware and then you sort of vote and
see what the right answer to that about
the output and then your productivity is
like 33 yeah that's pathetic it's
different for Networks what I did here
was I added an extra row of routers
okay and so I've only increased the
hardware by a fractional amount that's
the first thing and yet I get you know
multiple paths this way I'll get three
more paths
right now I'm getting that for just one
row of hardware
the second thing I want to point out is
which is the Redundant row
because I put it in a toroid you can't
tell because this ends up to your
redundant row of these guys this ends up
the Redundant row of the other guys Etc
and the last thing I want to point out
they're all doing useful work they're
routed I actually drop packets you know
local packets are in or out from these
routers so they're all doing useful work
at the same time and so
this is a fractional cost and hardware
and all 100 productivity
all right now how much does this extra
Hardware cost you know fractional
Hardware there's a funny thing that
happens with numbers when you're doing
this you'll see that okay if I range
these 12 routers in uh sort of three row
three rows and four columns it will be
non-fault tolerant because I don't have
enough levels to make fault tolerance
however if I just squeeze this thing
into like four rows of three columns
then it's full tolerant
and you say what's going on here you
know it's the same number of routers
what I've done is just basically change
the aspect ratio yes you have to do like
a when you compute the number of hops
you do you might have to do a fractional
number of more hops but you're getting
fault tolerance for no extra Hardware
okay and no extra links because you have
the same number of links there
all right
this is one of those cynical comments
though when you work at Bellas when sort
of a young naive engineer goes there you
get this bold you know sort of decrepit
uh old engineer and he's trying to
impart this wisdom to you and uh wisdom
one guy gave to me was a customer will
never pay for fault tolerance so long as
it is cheaper to blame
and just fire somebody for the fault
okay that used to be the adage the
wisdom and so now we can go back and
save some poor guy at his job by saying
oh just change the aspect ratio
it shows you that fault tolerance
becomes different
say thanks for laughing gives me some
feedback you're encouraging me all right
what you really want to do now you have
this funny thing is you've got this
abstract network of all these nodes and
you say Alan that this is not the
internet like I know this is sort of an
abstract thing how can you make it real
well you can make it real by assigning a
city to each one of these routers and
then you're like oh okay Alan what's the
right assignment I'm trying to do these
nodes to cities or cities to routers
and it turns out
the way to find it you know you can do
this sort of like a
um uh sort of the the best guess you say
Okay most packets go through New York
City all right and so what I'll do is
I'll do the the cities that are have
that share the most traffic with New
York City only one hop away and so I'll
put Chicago there oh here's another
question I'll put uh Los Angeles there
and then up here it's like oh I should
put one to Dallas and oh the other one
here goes to Washington DC you know for
all the funding
all right so
but you kind of Wonder is is that the
right one is that the Autumn one what
happens if I located here you will get
an advantage and the way to figure that
out is basically there's only n
factorial combinations
all right so you can basically go
through all the different combinations
and compute all the routing tables
figure out how many hops it is to all
the possible destinations with the Trap
and then weight each one of these things
with the amount of packets that you get
the real traffic and then look for the
one the configuration that has the
minimum number of Pops per packet
for the whole network
okay once you do that you'll see magical
things happen right you can also if you
sort of like feel a little queasy about
Alan this is going to look kind of funky
you can also factor in miles there so if
hops times miles between the
destinations per packet and see and try
to minimize and find out which is the
the best configuration for that
all right
but then you say Alan this is still not
geographical you've got this sort of
like strange you know Cube you know
looks like the bore the The Borax Cube
you know how am I going to ever sell
this or it doesn't seem to make any
sense
and so what I did was you can basically
suppose each one with sort of like a
washer and all these things are are
elastics now you can just sort of like
pull all the elastics and go to the
different cities or something like that
and all the red lines will be uh the
links that you have to establish and I
tried that okay I used to sort of bluff
that and sort of like wave my hands and
say oh you could do that but this is
another covid thing it was like I had
nothing else better to do why don't I
actually try to draw this and so I tried
with
um you know washers and elastics and I
forgot the name of that gay twister I
think it was Twister it reminded me of
Twister because once you lift up the
wrong thing the thing Springs in there
and everything gets all messed up again
all right so what I did was in Microsoft
Vizio free commercial here you know
inline uh ad
um on each one of the sort of like um uh
sort of like router symbols or something
I could establish pins or you know
points and uh then I could just connect
sort of uh elastic wires to these points
and I said what the heck let's see if I
can break Microsoft Vizio
and I just pulled it to the right cities
and this is what happened
okay and so
um
the wonders of Microsoft Vizio
um I've talked about what does an
optimal Network look like you know you
see okay you've got all these links here
this is looking kind of a little bad
because you're sort of like stretch
these fibers over you know you're going
to do new fibers through from Los
Angeles to New York and I might go
through my backyard and who's got the
money for this you know it's going to
take so long all this other stuff watch
all right we're talking how can we
implement it
what happens I gotta give you a little
lecture here about Optical
Communications uh as I said that's
another one of my specialties each cable
that sort of goes between cities or the
nearest city
uh usually yes 36 ribbons and each
ribbon has 24 fibers in it and so that
makes 864 fibers for each cable
okay and to tell you the truth they
probably drag maybe four cables at the
same time I mean once they they've sort
of like dug their trench they might as
well throw a few more cables in it the
cables aren't very wide those cables are
only about maybe two inches in diameter
um then on each one of those fibers I
can stick in 40 dense wdm channels in
other words here's the spectrum that is
possible for uh you know for Optics
going through uh um it's a glass on an
optical fiber you'll see there's certain
ones you can't do because that's you get
a water loss there from water but you
have uh we'll be talking about c-band
which is between uh uh 1.531 to
19571 you fit in 40 bands within that or
channels of wdm channels this used to be
telecommunications but now you can buy
this not quite off of Amazon but close
all right then each one of these
channels you can put 16 bits use 16 bit
qualm okay this is what the qualms look
like you're changing the amplitude and
the phase so they can sort of squeeze 16
bits in there and
um
it ends up what's nice about this from
an electronic point of view is you can
grab all 16 bits at the same time
with electronics in other words you can
demodulate it at the same time and it
means that your electronics doesn't have
to run 16 times faster you can use it
the same stuff but you still like have
all these demodulators there and you can
grab or you parallel and grab all the
bits at the same time uh in
telecommunications they're now working
at 64 or also like uh 128 or 256 count
uh qualm is what they're sort of aiming
for but 16 as I said it's sort of like a
little above Amazon uh access all right
uh quality where you you can't well yes
I'll show you that you you probably can
buy some all right uh the data rate is
usually about 100 gigabits per Channel
and given all the channels that you can
get that means you're probably gonna get
four terabits per second
and uh each uh Netflix stream is about
12 or 10 megabits per second so you can
compute to see how many Netflix channels
there are
um
and the finer cruncher on this is most
of these fibers are still dark they're
not there's no light going through them
it was like what what happened is that
the VC's event uh the investment lines
we buried that thing all and so it's got
a future worth and so I think it's sort
of like fun to get all this funding for
all the future value of all these fibers
but the demand hasn't quite built up but
they've got all these fibers buried
there so someday they're going to recoup
their losses but most of them are still
dark
so it's there you don't have to dig up
anyone's you know driveway you don't
have to do other things like that in
fact what you do is it used to be you
call up a level three and say I want a
connection between New York and Los
Angeles and it's like oh is it going to
take it used to be two business weeks a
two a two uh basically 10 days but now I
think it's even lower
they just sort of sit there and type in
and the connection appears all right so
what happens is
why are you doing all this all right it
ends up if you look at what an optical
node is you know all the stuff like
comes into Denver or something like that
you have a setup like this and you
basically have a fiber coming in and it
goes into a demultiplexer that breaks it
into many different channels you come
into a optical Matrix switch
and then from that you tap off some
things either they go bypass and go
straight out or some of them get end up
rounded through a router and then come
back and then go out the optical
firewood this multiplexer shown here is
the exact same type of component that's
the one shown up there the way they work
is kind of find interesting you're
basically said light coming down one of
these things all these different
different radius wave guides and it
turns out that the the light of a
certain wavelength can't make it through
a certain type of curvature and so it
basically gets lost in the substrate and
it's kind of cool and that's how they do
the filter that's how they separate the
different wave wise
all right I'm doing this as completely
gratuitous as free Consulting whether
you asked for it or not what I was kind
of upset when I was doing this thing was
that all this technology exists there
but very few people are using it right
now and I couldn't understand why it
used to be that there was a
telecommunications Market that was like
uh doing the dense wgm and that was like
thousands of dollars for components then
there used to be these cheaper ones for
data centers for the the computer users
and uh those were like maybe a factor of
maybe four cheaper okay but what has
happened now is both markets have merged
and so it's almost the same price and I
looked up the prices yesterday to give
you a feeling for what's going on this
is for one channel going through uh and
this thing is capable of handling 40
channels on the same fiber so you first
have uh 10 gig uh ethernet basically on
copper you go through one of these
things which you basically a power
supply for the modules and a little
connectivity uh it goes and one of the
outputs is one of this is a optical
transceiver this one can do anywhere or
you can order from Channel 17 through
61. it's 10g it's dense wdm and it has a
sort of mechanical form factor at SFP
plus that means what type of logical
plug into uh the spacing between the
bands is 100 gigabits gigahertz it can
only go 80 kilometers and it cost you
319 dollars
you go into one of these things you need
it handles two fibers at a time and you
usually use one for transmit and the
other for receives and uh this one you
buy it all together they charge you 170
1 600 99 you go into like a kilometer of
optical fiber these are two strands of
optical fiber it's about a thousand
bucks so it's about a dollar per meter
for two two strands of fiber so it's
like 50 cents of fiber and
um
uh your return path goes the opposite
way through this
I'll tell you a few things even this was
kind of inflated
um you can probably knock off
400 off of this price these guys uh
they're charging you an awful lot for
the box and you just go on AliExpress
and look around and you can figure that
out this one you can make it a little
cheaper you can probably reduce the
price by a factor of two if you sort of
were willing to roll your own fiber in
other words sort of put the connectors
on the end or something like that and
just buy the fiber in bulk
um you have to understand all these
systems this is the expensive part it's
the labor this stuff is cheap you can
upgrade this the faster you know all
these other things later this is that's
noise this is an expensive part and so
if you're some sort of poor academic
someplace in some campus and you're
begging your Dean to make it let you put
another fiber you know to another
building or you're sort of like in a
Data Center and you just need the more
connection you should go to the boss and
say hey look I saw this on the top why
don't we do this or something and then
we can do 40 fibers to replace the fiber
that is already hung between the
buildings and then they'll give you
tenure and you know you'll be a hero
right this is one of the things that uh
Fusion you get the two fibers together
and it basically just melts it and keeps
the connection there this used to be
like three dollar four thousand dollars
each
and uh the waiting period was like
almost a year
now you can buy it off AliExpress again
all right outline I've talked about how
you can implement it and how can you
deploy this how do you get it out there
and this becomes more of a people issue
the other ones were technology the lab
the top one was sort of like a wet wear
all right first thing I have to sort of
introduce you because some people might
not know this has to do with pgp this is
networking uh it's called the BG pgp
it's border Gateway protocol and what
happens is every router has this map of
the world and it sort of like knows it's
like the signpost at the beginning of
MASH TV programs where it's a you know
300 miles this way to New York 500 miles
of this way so the way that the router
figures out how to move the package is
it asks the neighbors the the router
hooked on the other end of each Port
what's your routing table looks like
give it to me and so the router gathers
all these routers these things together
and
um they gather all these tables together
and the algorithm you basically select
which is the fastest way the least
number of hops to get to New York then
you sort of add one to it you know and
stuff like that and so you generate the
table
what I realized or something like pgp is
really a gradient descent algorithm this
is how it figures out what the shortest
way is it's sort of like finds it tosses
out all the different ways to go between
Chicago and New York and pixta it only
memorized the ones that's the the
shortest ones and that's literally it
it's it's a gradient descent algorithm
all right so
uh why are you gonna do all this Ellen
you know what was the nitty-gritty
There It Is I've got a connection
between Los Angeles and New York and
then I have some routers one or more
routers in the way where a lot of the
packets are going and I'm proposing you
connect Los Angeles directly to New York
and that sounds a little ridiculous but
first I'll show you what happens when
you do
all right here's what a network
Engineers do they have their own little
view of the world which is their Network
and they want to alleviate all the
saturated links
all right and they sort of like oh maybe
we can throw another Link in there to
distribute some of the traffic between
uh let's say here it's like oh some of
these links are saturated here and so
maybe I can add another link between Los
Angeles and Chicago and that will take
the some of the packets off of this all
the other links what they also do is
they aggregate on your underutilized
ports and notice if they come in here
and they say well there's two inputs to
this router that are only like fifty
percent used one we just sort of take
out one of those links or something and
then force all the traffic to go on that
one port and then we can free up a port
and so you sort of view them what what
their whole life is it's sort of like a
video game they're trying to reduce
tourist packets those are the packets
that sort of go through their router and
really don't want to get off and really
they just are like hi you know and you
know it's like they want to minimize
that because they want to preserve their
router uh they don't have to buy a
bigger router so the way to look at
these Network Engineers this is not a
I'm trying to do it as not a direct not
a loop not to put them down all right
but they're sort of like demons in an
operating system their whole thing is
I'm going to optimize I'm going to
optimize I'm gonna optimize and so
they're the lowest level of this
optimization and they're perfectly happy
you just sort of feed them Donuts you
know and they're just they just do this
all the time the problem is that they do
this for both the optimal and
sub-optimal links they don't have any
idea when they're looking at their small
view of the world what they should be
really doing on a bigger picture and so
what we're doing here what I'm proposing
is basically suddenly telling them or
indirectly what the optimal connection
should be and they have to so they're
doing what they do they will normally
optimize to take advantage of that
uh I have a analogy having to do with
interstate highway
if you ever driven across country that
used to be my thing so I've done every
possible way you're going around Route
80 or something like that and you come
across these exits that say business
district you go through here well once
at a time it wasn't an exit the real
early Highway like Route 66 actually
went through that town went through the
business district and went through all
the stoplights and so
um
what that finally happened is when they
put in the Super Highway they basically
said okay we're going to bypass that and
so the traffic didn't go by the all
those stop lights and it just went on on
the route 80 or route 66. yeah or route
uh 40. and
then what happens is some Senator uh
figured this out and said hey why don't
we make a topology out of this in other
words rather than having all these
connections that go from east coast to
West Coast why don't we do some
north-south connections and then they
quote invented a grid and that's
basically they've added to apology into
the highway system so um
a little footnote uh Gore claimed he was
the inventor of the internet his father
was the one who came up with this idea I
think later on some other people came up
with the idea of doing the north south
runs
Eisenhower was also involved in that all
right because he thought he can move
tanks around them
um
all right what my proposal here is
I've showed you how to make a real
redundant beefy you know redundant
Network that's massively optimal and
what I'm trying to say is we should just
see this or graph this on top of the
regular internet right now and then
quote turn on this network and let pgb
pgp do its thing and it'll just saturate
all these lines within seconds
okay and then some network engineer is
going to say oh we've got some saturated
links here and but our other things are
these other connections are just our
lost traffic all of a sudden what we
should do is sort of like move some of
the extra links or com compact them and
move some of the links and maybe
strengthen the link that's sort of like
it's been saturated
and uh
so basically there's a line here is your
cannibalize the less efficient links and
to strengthen the seated Network the
more optimal Network
I said Alan you know this is still
a little hard to swallow
a few things to make this a little more
palatable some of these segments already
exist
and so in some respects so many
connections between here already but
there's a few routers in the way and so
as I said the network Engineers would
basically basically get the Kinks out of
these links and so they become like
straight links so that's a normal thing
that happens and then eventually they're
gonna have to say well we're gonna have
to bypass some of these things some of
this traffic on the major nodes so uh
this mechanism will partly happen
in other words some segments already
exist and then we'll be normally flushed
out by the links being strengthened what
has happened another thing is you can do
it incrementally you don't have to do
this whole thing at the same time all
you do is set one link and it'll
saturate and you fix that you know the
all right and then some other time when
you get a little more funding you can
put in another link or tell the people
to link up you know together and that
becomes a second link and that's fine
you're heading towards a global enter
and optimized internet
the last thing I'm saying this is a hot
slide you don't have to shut things down
to do this you just do it now and uh
Bell Labs used to be famous for
something called a hot slide and it's
basically where you can set in network
equipment while this network was running
and I just saw it as a sort of like a
a riff or something a
could do
an honoring thing that this is also a
hot slide
all right you're saying okay Ellen what
makes you think you can get a wave
system you know aren't you violating
like the law of gravity or something you
know
okay so what happens is we've all been
grown up you know but this is religion
this is like the not the quite 12
tablets but for networking people this
is pretty close to the 12 tablets uh the
OSI OSI stack
and so what happened is if you look at
it
Network topology is outside of the stack
pgp is way up there on the level seven
all right it controls some other levels
but it's only moving uh routing cables
around
and
routing tables really don't tell you the
topology they just told you the
connectivity
but there's a difference okay and so uh
I'm saying the reason why I can get away
with this I can Muck around with this
thing and all this stuff will still work
it's past it'll be clueless of what I
actually did underneath
this is a snarky comment of mine
um every decade or so there was a
movement to design the Next Generation
internet
it started off as a battle between
hardware and protocols and that software
then it devolved into a battle between
protocols
and uh I find it a little ironic that
the solution might be just math
it's just sort of like both of them lose
all right last thing okay suppose it's
like one of the things if you did one
minute what would happen
as I said uh Cheswick I asked them you
know last year how many hops do you
think it's going to cross the internet
now that you know after two decades
and he says well it's probably somewhere
between 30 and 40 hops you know you say
okay so you can go out on your you know
you go to your local ISP it's sort of
like somehow goes rambling around the
Bay Area gets onto one of the the large
isps like a t or or uh Comcast it goes
rattling along and then what happens is
you're stuck you have to sort of go
switch from one of the large networks to
the other large network uh carrier and
so that takes a few hops and then you
have to go through their sort of like
ISP nests around their city and then you
finally get to the ISP where you want to
go and so that quickly becomes 30 to 40
hops
uh suppose you wanted to connect the top
64 isps together and you're doing this
with routers that only connect to four
directions you might have several ports
but they're only connected in four
directions
and so yeah so I have a fan on the floor
and um so if you do this computation is
log base 4 or 64 plus one that's four
hops so I I should be able to get
between any one of those 64 uh isps and
four hops and that's a lot better than
30 to 40. all right
when you reduce hops you reduce the
latency
that's quite obvious in other words if
you go through the bypass you're only
taking
like nanoseconds when you go through the
router you're talking milliseconds
and so you're really cutting the latency
by reducing the number of hops you also
reduce the power because the only thing
that uses power really is the router and
not the the rest are sort of passive
components
um you also reduce the amount of like
torch you need because if you the more
you can sort of push out into these
bypass networks the less router Hardware
of what you'll need and ultimately you
reduce the cost
to run the system your cost to upgrade
the system because it'll be more
efficient
um the last one is what when you
increase the redundancy you're
increasing the fault tolerance so like
if Chicago or if Texas goes offline or
something like that you can get around
it and uh the next thing is you're
reviewing traffic congestion and other
ones and everyone's tuning into you know
something of Thrones or something like
that you know it's going to saturate the
internet in fact that's what happened
when uh you when Netflix started
happening it basically killed an hour if
you didn't notice at that point all
right
um
methodology all I'm suggesting here is
first you select a mathematically
optimal Network you can pick anyone you
want you can do yeah and make it by you
know I don't care just pick up an
optimal Network and then you can
increase the redundancy you know the
tricks you can increase the reduce the
number of hops by making a toroid and
all this other stuff that's just sort of
like uh engineering stuff
um then when you're selecting the node
assignment this is just comfortable
search you just do all the different
combinations and you evaluate all right
and um
the last one is you just sort of recast
the network and that's sort of like a
drafting problem
and then you just sort of seed this
you're going to get someone to fund it
at the very beginning someone has to
sort of put these fibers in and all you
have to do is sort of keep it
temporarily like for a month because
what will happen is the network should
learn I mean all the network Engineers
will figure out that they should
strengthen that connection and so
because all the packets are going to be
pouring to this more efficient Network
and so but you just have to start the
ball rolling so this was a hope for the
seed Network
and this is just catalpies the less
efficient links to strength strengthen
the seed Network
um
what happened is people sort of think
I'm doing good
you know this is Magic this is you know
whatever this isn't fair there's
something wrong with this
what I'm doing here is I'm doing reverse
optimization
well we're sort of like given a system
you know the way we optimize it we turn
all the knobs and see you know try not
to break it see what the Hep it up I
mean we all do this all right and we've
got a little more sophisticated we make
a computer model and then we adjust all
the parameters you know Until It Breaks
all I'm doing is I'm doing this in
Reverse I'm picking an optimal Network
and then beefing it up and then
customizing it so that it would be good
for you know the regular traffic the
packet traffic and then I am just
stretching it to sort of force it on to
the real geographical constraints so
it's backwards I'm not looking from the
current Internet trying to figure out
what the audible trying to get out
though I'm starting to Optimal and
getting matching it to the current
Internet
ah
there's also applicability of just the
United States Postal Service they have
they don't have buffer delay they have
waiting dock delay they have to wait for
the next
truck to come by so the mail just sort
of sits on their trucks or sits on the
dock and so they can sort of like they
should go through this algorithm and
sort of see what they end up this works
for all logistical companies whether
it's the Army logistical company whether
it's uh you know UPS Etc
that was on
yeah but they don't have their own
distribution nowhere
um
but is it how many how many times you
have to touch the pack how many times
you have to touch the package to sort to
sort this thing out
uh all right
Alan if this is such a good idea why
hasn't happened yet
so in the early days when I was pushing
this
I thought it's me should I dye my hair
should I not dye my hair should I cut my
hair short do I have bad breath you know
one of the interesting byproducts of
growing older is you don't give a damn
anymore
you know it's like senior law there's
nothing you can do to me as I said I
wore a sweatshirt here or going across
the quad
um
the next one it's math and there's a
different levels of this okay first of
all
a lot of people
this is beyond them all right the second
thing is you can get mathematics and
intellectually you can know this okay so
when I said okay there's a login Network
you're willing to accept the fact that
there's okay login networks out there or
something like that because I'm a nice
trusting honest soul and stuff like that
all right
but you're not going to tell your
roommate or your boss this
you say oh there's a six Chinese six
foot tall Chinese guy told me this
that's why it's true that insufficient
what I showed you here is this is my
covet thing of a proof this is the
disguised mathematical proof that makes
it almost palatable now you can go to
your roommate and show hey I can do
something called gene pool engineering
or gene pool inheritance and show that I
can connect anything for anybody else
and then they go oh that's kind of
interesting okay second thing I showed
this this is another sort of covid
invention and it has to do with I used
to sort of bluff and I was lazy I would
talk about someday you know you just the
way you map this is a homomorphic
mapping I will tell you the proof of
that has horrendous no one understands
it you know and whatever it just sort of
like makes you be labeled as a
mathematician all right and then just
dismissed so
I would go through this whole you know
washer and elastic kind of routine you
know as a good shot you know sort of
like a mind exercise
but it was still not sufficient to make
people believe
and no one was going to buy all those
washers and elastics
so what I did was I did this in Vizio
and now you see the product of all those
equivalent to maximum and it's now real
okay and you will be able to show your
boss this or your roommate just see this
is what it looks like a few things from
this diagram you can see this is not
intuitively obvious that this is the
optimal settings technique all right and
in other words given an infinite a sub a
lot of monkeys or something drawing
things in Vizio you're not going to get
this network
and so unless you believe the
mathematics underneath it this looks
like complete garbage
okay if you don't have the mathematical
song and dance
okay this guy's crazy
okay my five-year-old could do this with
crayons you know that type of thing all
right
this is another yeah it's too big to fix
it's hopeless who am I going to talk to
on the internet you know who's in charge
of it it's distributed who has the power
to be able to change the internet this
is impossible
so what happens if you look at that this
is a distributed answer to a distributed
problem
which is kind of cool I thought you know
in other words all I have to do is sort
of like leadership show people which is
the way it should be and I don't have to
keep it there for a while and then the
forces that should should basically
reinforce the optimal route
all right
this is
a problem right now it's called tragedy
of the commons it basically when you
have something free or no one really
knows that they're paying for it they're
not going to approve it
you know it's good enough why should I
do it you know I've got other things to
do you know I've got to watch something
on Netflix I've got to go out on a date
you know something like that and so if
you look up as an economic term it's
basically
since it's public it's ubiquitous no
one's willing to sort of improve it or
cut the grass
I meant
the blame the bane of the internet is
that even mergers and acquisition
lawyers can Cobble something together
and it will still work
my starkiness
it's only too true
summary first uh basically how do you do
an optimal Network it looks like that
that's squeezing of all the connections
or how do you implement with a lot of
optical fiber that's already there how
can you deploy it you just sort of like
do this thing and then sort of like
field your dreams watch the packets come
um closure I mentioned how this was
connected to you know the optimal
internet
here's the clue what we did was we did
the Starlight switch which is the
bachelor Banyan and it was a switch a
packet switch that was based on a login
Network so deep in this thing is a login
Network
what happens is when we're sitting the
story is kind of funny
um Scott and I were sort of like we just
come in it's like Monday morning
uh our management wanted us to run bid
Eric Corrections on the on the machine
on the on the the switch
so every morning we got there we turned
on the thing it drew like about eight
kilowatts and so it sort of glowed in
the dark and we would be there sort of
put our feet next to it you know it was
like the potbelly stove and our nurser
nurse my first cup of coffee and here
with nurses first can of Diet Coke
and one day we just figured out like
we can take over the network
returning the whole network
login switch
so basically
this was inside this and now I'm trying
to distort the whole internet into this
so that was the secret
uh another snarky garment it's only
taken four decades in one pandemic to do
this so I'm a little laid back
um here are some quotes along the way
this is purely gratuitous it's like one
of those things maybe passing words of
wisdom or hopefully humorous or comments
um along the way I remember in my head
various quotes of this as I said this
started four decades ago 1981.
one was voice will remain King data will
be limited like facts and video will be
just at niche market
this guy repeated to me repeatedly by my
management at Bell labs this is a
research management this was the Mantra
that they all remembered
all right and this shows you where they
are
you know why they're
now a branding company all right next
thing is
during the day
one vice president of ATT said this to
me at the end of the meeting and it was
just absolutely depressing during the
day telecommunications is a tax on
business and during the night is a tax
on loneliness
so one of those things it's um
it was too true I had to look at him it
was so cynical I was worried that he was
going to cut his wrist and die in front
of me and get blood all over me it was
like one of those things it was it was
dark all right
um next one uh this is one of my
managers at bill
who is going to generate all this free
content for the World Wide Web
so I wanted to sort of confront him
again
um he's noted for another famous thing
um he recruits at Stanford used to
recruit at Stanford and I used to have
battles in his office about the the
packet length of ATM they wanted to bake
it 52 bites or you know long and I
thought that was absolutely crazy I was
pushing to link the packet size to the
Unix block size
and I remember he bought special
chocolates I'd go in there and do all
these calculations on the board and dust
all over the place and everything like
that and the way he finally found the
way to stop me doing these little rants
in his office all the time about the
stupid small packet link was he bought
these Tire lean pens that he had a white
board instead
and I was overcome by the fumes you know
I just sort of gave up giving the
presentations on this whiteboard so but
what happened was he's the guy who said
who's going to generate all the content
you know this is when they thought the
internet was just like CB radio so
passing fan all right
why would anyone else want why would
anyone want to send video over the
internet
I put in a proposal to DARPA
talking about how to analyze arrays of
routers and how they would handle voice
data and video
so the feedback I got back from the
DARPA was
never going to want to send video over
the internet
I did get the contract up
right in spite of that so I don't know
whether
well I don't know what happened all
right
this last one or this one can you show
me the perfect Shuffle card trick again
it might come in handy someday to
impress some chicken a bar
all right the perfect shovel is if you
get 16 playing cards and you perfectly
shuffle them four times you'll see the
cards will end up exactly the same way
so this is a classic thing on the
kitchen group Theory
and this is from a VC
and I can't remember whether he was on
you Sand Hill Road or University Avenue
but so those were the the Bro days I
guess you know about uh I think you have
some chicken bar or something
um
oh it was a predecessor between before
the Bro period
um
this is when I was uh giving a
presentation to a large router company
in Silicon Valley
and it got down to they were going to
analyze my my thing and they're
debriefing me or something like that and
there's two engineers in a room or
something like and then one guy had to
go to the bathroom so he left a room the
other guy turns to me and says
you got to go to the fancy School
Stanford I had to go to UC Berkeley on
scholarship
at that time I realized he was going to
flush my idea just because he had had to
go to Berkeley and I had gone to
Stanford
I mean this is like one of those things
all I can think at that time is to throw
up you know
he was like in his mid-30s and it was
still you know oh yeah he couldn't get
into Stanford [ __ ] you all right
um
what type of wood was that
all right what happened was I spent
about a month or something trying to
convince the president of bell
Laboratories so this is after I left to
write me a letter of introduction to the
chairman of the board of ATT
so that I might be able to put my idea
forth to them
okay and so he volunteered to do it he
was like really happy he sent the letter
off or something
and two weeks later I could just call in
the telephone
and it was the Special Assistant to a
vice president of ATT I was like wow you
know I had practiced my talk my Spiel
you know it's not quite 45 seconds but
you can see I can talk pretty fast but
it was like okay here's my shield here's
my time to do it and the guy was really
interactive he asked questions you know
he's taking copious notes and everything
like that and so I said oh I got this
man I got the message across and then
all of a sudden he says oh excuse me
what type of wood was that
yeah
wood wood
why would you ask wood
I said n log N Network
and he thought the log meant would
and I was stuck having to go I just
completely disintegrated at that point I
mean it was just you sort of watched me
just so I turned into you know in a
dissolved intellectual dissolve and it
was like I had to go in the rest of my
Spiel luckily it was an automatic but
that has haunted me that phrase what
type of wood was that
and this is the indirect way of why I'm
giving this talk at Stanford 380. My
Hope Is that someone in the audience
knows that there's there's logs that
don't deal with wood all right that's
the end
so that's it
um
notice of me
yes I'm listening yeah okay
uh question what's kind of route in
protocol you're supposed to have in that
uh switch Network
nothing just what you have now no change
okay and if you
uh looking to make sure you do have to
make sure your pgp will know how to deal
with equal hop paths
okay so if you have four routes to New
York
instead of doing round robin between all
the four idactical ports you know of
going out you should basically hash on
some of the bits on your uh Source
packet
uh your Source address so that all the
packets from the same Source end up
going out the same port on your router
what happens in case of one link fails
excuse me what happens if one link fails
one router one link fails at the end
okay what happens is pgp handle side one
link fails or something it basically
signals you know there's a wait period
or something like that and then the pgp
tables get routed or re-re-shuffled and
they basically take that path out of the
network
quickly
so at a high load it would propagate
waves of load back from uh end of router
to Source routers yes I do
you know in other words if you're if
it's a tcpi link or something like that
yes you will get uh basically sort of
like back pressure all the way back no
no I'm not thinking about pressure I'm
telling you I'm selling about waves
because
uh where propagation time of routing
decision from back to uh Arizona has
sent and it would create some waves of
overload uh
uh periodically on routers on some on
their Center May create okay depending
from failure
we are talking about a bad link
propagating back and failed uh yeah if
some if something is congested in
surfing this congestion where we when
you uh you need to be really careful to
do not have a congestion waves in this
kind of network
uh it doesn't know this network when
that link fails or something like all
the tables get updated
you know and all things happen how often
it could could supposed to be updated
immediately
oh some TCP uh tables get updated like
30 seconds per minute you can set that
you know it's just that's really small
it turns the traffic between the routers
you know those labels get just all the
time so do you uh no no okay sorry
I'll let uh give a chance to our people
to okay thanks
I'm live you can throw tomatoes at me
I don't bite
I actually showed you just life after
Stanford
okay I'm fine kind of sweaty yeah
yes the um
and you thought probably at the
beginning this was just a scam
you thought this was going to be one of
those academic exercises again I was
like oh sure you know who can optimize
the internet and now you should make a
poster you can internalize the internet
in other words if you optimize your
local land or your local land if you
have more than four nodes on any of your
networks you can do this and every
little bit helps you know just can't
tell whether you know what routes gets
routed through your campus and this
works as I said on lands on your data
center
Etc on your network so you can become a
hero and just go there but the trouble
is you're gonna have to explain what
logs are and you know go through the
solution determine the kind of tree what
and determine the kind of yeah they kind
of trade just make something up you know
they'll be fine for them they all know
the difference okay
so can it feel like an open source
Community where you know people will
start optimizing their local lunch to
stay propagated yes and the truth it's
interesting how it finds the truth
is basically the people enter in you
know oh this doesn't work or whatever
and so it's iterative and you get these
sort of road maps through the universe
and what is the truth it Maps it out and
so it's kind of cute I've always admire
is Wikipedia and how it works it's
distributed there's another one of those
things how do you get to some consensus
this way is sort of like the opposite of
trying to find you know here I suggest
you do this and the all the the minions
underneath should optimize towards it
eventually it knows routers know what's
up to all passed we might not know but
it knows I can figure that out all right
how do I log off here no you don't have
to do it
I'll take care of that okay thank you
very much okay thank you